I got a couple questions for you just
get ready for this I'll help you draw
know I'm kind of secure now me and they
got always what I do baby
this is Serge Ibaka aka my first chef
welcome to anger are you today I will be
cooking for Tiffany Haddish I see a lot
of pizza boxes in here so that mean the
crew don't want to eat whatever he
making Tiffany loves to garden so today
I'm making warm salad
[Music]
ready so now I'm but world too warm how
to make sure Burma warm before I cooked
it because I want to be clean
well this is warning I'm gonna build the
salad oh man this is gonna look so good
nice time to fry those creepy cards a
little bit of garlic always necessary
can you smell that
[Music]
mmm what is he making like I think
you're taking like a swan and then in it
because I play the shark Lena make board
not kind of it's me looking this bad by
winning once you try it enjoy it
trust me oh no this testing
[Music]
it took me like two three hours to cook
this food for you
really I'm the first movie star that's
been here - anyway alright yes you
better put the time I did my only thing
is you have to make sure you have to eat
that food I'll eat it as long as it's
prepared its prepare one choice for me
yeah I can't wait I never come to a
party especially a dinner party
empty-handed I got a couple questions
for you just get ready for the about you
okay now I'm scared but people when I
watch is this show pg-13 it's pg-13 yeah
okay cool
I got yummy I know how to edit myself
you know I got your great show coming
out with a bunch of kids cause you kids
say the darndest things okay I'll just
talk to you like I would talk to one of
them very good I've done lots of talk
shows - they'll know if you know this
but I kills talk shows let's go okay
next question
right yeah I don't wash anything yeah
okay I'm gonna take my time - oh yeah
you know I'd like to take my turn I
don't know you know take my time I
thought I mean even when I cook this
food for you I took my time okay well
when I cook the food for you it was
right when I got off did it and I did it
with a smile put some love on there -
and when I did it with a smile I did a
lot of its money and nobody I don't know
what your definition of love no love is
long I don't share with everybody you
can share it over you can share enjoy
share my love you can sheer joy I show
my love of people I don't know yeah
that's a lot of basketball players know
[Laughter]
how does it feel being a black woman in
the feeling industry I guess it feels
pretty normal cuz I don't know what it
feels normal
I don't know what it feels like to be
any other kind of person in the film
industry cuz I've only been a black
woman but you know I'm right on paper on
my paperwork I check the right box
because I did my 23andme and I have a
percentage of Caucasian in me when I
fill out my paperwork I claim my white
side you see that's why that's a healthy
you be in the Hollywood I don't know if
they help me be successful in Hollywood
but I know it helps with like taxes and
my black card if my credit score is
already planning to wipe my credit score
with 0.08 hundreds now since I've been a
white water oh wow
yeah but being a black woman in this
business is it can be challenging I
don't think about it that way everything
that I do like stand-up comedy and in
doing comedic movies that's kind of a
man's world and so I figure okay if how
did the boys play I'm gonna try to play
like how they play I go hard in the
paint you just go hard a pen I go hard
you know what I like that because you
inspire a lot of women and you have to
keep up thank him my daughter she
watches your movies oh yeah that Tori my
daughter I wasn't shooting with you I
didn't notice my daughter no you are the
kids not me I was like you know her she
said like of course that she's my lady
okay okay okay
you know I'm international yeah yeah see
I'm popping all over the world what is
your book about my book is about me how
about you yeah yeah - the last black
unicorn it's about my journey from you
know being a kid going through the
foster care system being homeless being
married let's say no you're rich richer
no I'm not rich rich but no how can
afford solar panels now so what was your
first big break I think my first big
break is when I did stand-up on the
Arsenio Hall Show
you see loving do that I love stand-up
that's my first love that's like I'm
sure that's my baby are you making my
money and doing movies right for sure
no oh wow and you said you they're like
originally I haven't slowed down what
was it like hosting sinner yeah
SNL sinan okay no I'm gay
what was it like hosting SNL I learned a
lot about myself hosting SNL it was a
dream of mine to be on the show like to
be a cast member and then to be asked
the host was like super huge for me and
I had this notebook like this thick
we're all kind of sketchy characters
that I've written and stuff and so when
I came in there I was like hey I want to
do all this and they're like um you know
this is a machine that's been running
for over 40 years
we got a certain way that we like to do
things you do whatever you want in your
monologue but we gonna take care of
everything else and so I was like
actively trying to get people to do my
ideas they was like no we're gonna do
what we do so I was mad maybe for like a
day and a half I lost 10 pounds so that
was real yeah I lost 10 pounds cuz I was
stressed out I was really mad cuz I was
like no no we're gonna do this and then
I just put all my energy into my
monologue and I want to me and I was a
very funny dude I can't American female
stand-up comedian to ever host it you
think it will win an Emmy I did not
think I would win it in me I didn't even
know you could get it in me for hosting
you know I didn't know that until they
said Tiffany Haddish you're nominated
for it I mean I was like what
like right now I'm nominated for like
four people Choice Awards I didn't even
I'm like what does that mean they're
like people like what you did I'm like
oh that's good
cool and they're like can you promote
that and I'm like oh you go for mud
they're like to say no they are like
saying it's that make videos yeah you
should do it yeah but we're begging for
votes oh you did ask a Bigfoot vote
yeah I'm like why would I do that but if
you're interested in voting for Tiffany
Adams
for Emmy for best my dad my bed I know
you proved yeah go ahead
do you really poo in your exit chute yes
I did poop in my exertion what in some
Jordans oh yeah I'm shameless piece yeah
he was more than pissed he was mad yeah
I was more mad he cheated on me Oh on
videotape on my birthday I was very
upset I was emotional and I felt like he
had pulled on my soul so then I decided
to pull and the solar issues well then I
asked me if you want to go play
basketball cuz we used to play
basketball together out of time he had
just got these brand-new Jordans and he
left them at my house and so I put them
right over my booty hole and put this
shoe back in the box and I brought
rocket box jumping back in upon you oh
my gosh brought him over to his house
okay it was like babe let's go play
basketball put your new J's on you're
gonna kill him on the court you're gonna
be the Flyers do on the court in your
new J's and he put his foot in the shoe
foot out and I made sure I ate corn too
so that he knew it was human and he
pulled his foot on it he was like oh my
god somebody get my shoe and I was like
yes Father
you put me through now you walk in me
and mother and I ran our paths right and
I knew he wasn't gonna chase me because
he's not gonna track blew out through
his mama Wow
that's what I know why you find idea
because I was man I would just want to
get revenge
without going to jail these are things I
think every woman thinks of stuff like
this and they've made maybe they don't
act on it energy and I acted on it that
time if y'all want I'm putting on my new
special in December the 3rd in that
special I'm talking about ways to get
revenge without going to jail check it
out it's called black Mitzvah he's for
women all means myth I guess make it do
these things - yeah I mean you could you
could poop in the Stiletto I guess I
mean if they would see it I mean get you
big it'd probably be too much
who is this a of course oh I like number
27 on the New York Yankees his name is
Jean Carlos panting and then also I like
Leonardo DiCaprio like Michael B Jordan
Oh like Trevor Noah
Trevor Noah okay does the ice a
precaution yeah I have a little variety
back none of them like me like that but
you know it's okay how you know because
I've approached them I mean I walk right
up to Leonardo I was like what do you do
baby what is the craziest thing you ever
the craziest thing I ever a was wrecked
Sigyn rat all right eighty vexed big
what a small one it was pretty big we're
in Japan
okay yeah I was long as thick I thought
it was chicken it was delicious
you know it was a dollar each stick
right so I was like I was killing it I
was on my fourth stick and they was like
you'd like that a lot like yeah I love
this then there's like it's rat I was
like is what and it was like it's right
and I was like it's late bring me one
more thing I'm sure you will enjoy what
I disken for you didn't what it is it's
it's better it's cocaine isn't that
right no no no way far from that it's
good you love it okay before I present
you the meal mm-hmm I have a three spicy
question for you if you don't answer
those missions I've some drink you have
to drink shot there to take a shot okay
a shot away he's a cricket team you know
I grew up in together so I'm sure I've
eaten lots of roaches in my time yeah
you don't make it thick - okay question
number one was co-star in a movie
where's co-star yeah you was co-star in
the movie was in oh okay so I was in
this movie car Keanu okay and the cat
was the worst do the cat
you can't you turn down yes oh you know
what yeah I did hook up okay so search
I've answered all your little spicy
questions I think you should be drinking
your drink no yeah you got a drink it
I'll give you one question in my phase
one of this day okay so why do you look
[Applause]
hungry are you I'm very hungry
I know you dr. garden yes I love to
garden I made you silent okay setup but
it's warm salad mealworms you're not
gonna cook them first nah coop door
without going away so you made a salad
yeah yeah and it's a cute two hours too
late how they take you two hours to make
some damn without judgment you know why
I want you to make sure this dude let me
see you in one of those don't you wanna
try it okay
it's my yeah what about what I cook for
you I want to try to hear Geordi George
did you put it in there
okay Geordi thank you for doing that I
cook for you to both you look like
you've real hungry I am hungry
I made it gravy gravy some rice and I
had a sauteed some okra is enjoy but do
you want a little bit of salad you
should get a little family for your
place let me pray over it first hold up
Heavenly Father I put your throne in
your son's neck please let these meal
mine make me sick and give me ain't kind
of infection something like that cuz I
hate to be on the front page saying a
search pocket gave me an infection all
right Amy and then okay let's do it
what do you think I were to sell it
no bad one okay let's do it
all right so did you make this yourself
oh yeah oh wow okay I see you live Oh
chicken huh you wanna party no see
that's piggy you eaten poaching well
what was pitching city birds huh what is
what is fine with Jody
I told you but you like it I mean you
like it keep eating your no is chicken
come on you yes I know it's just good
because you know you never know I'm sure
you get [ __ ] I sure it's chicken all
right it's good for her to see though
you're my first guest
we'll finish everything and tell you I
was on without touching coconut milk
well I'm gonna leave it nothing it's
nothing you talking to one of the
brightest people in a guy
no you are I'll give you that she not
scared of nothing
I'm not a policeman
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]